on on the topic of adaptive modeling and
you talk about lifelong learning which
is a
i think a topic that's understudied
or maybe because nobody knows what to do
with it but like you know if you look at
alexa
or most of our artificial intelligence
systems that are primarily machine
learning based systems
or dialogue systems all those kinds of
things they know very
little about you in the sense of the
life
long learning sense that we
learn as humans we learn a lot about
each other
not in the quantity effects but like
the temporally rich
set of information that seems to like
pick up the
crumbs along the way that somehow seems
to capture a person pretty well
do you have any ideas how to uh how to
do
lifelong learning uh because it seems
like most of the machine learning
community does not
no well by the way not only does machine
learning community not not spend a lot
of time on lifelong learning they don't
i don't think they spend a lot of time
on
uh learning period in the sense that
they tend to be very task focused
everybody is over fitting to whatever
problem is they happen to have they're
over engineering their solutions
to the task even the people and i think
these people do
are trying to solve a hard problem of
transfer learning right i'm going to
learn on one task and learn another test
it's you still end up creating the task
you know it's like looking for your keys
where the light is because that's where
the light is right it's not because the
keys have to be there
i mean one could argue that we tend to
do this in general we tend to kind of
do it as a group we tend to he'll climb
and get stuck in local optima
and i think we do this in the small the
small as well i think it's very hard to
do
um because so look
here's the hard thing about ai right the
hard thing about ai is it keeps changing
on us right
you know what is ai is the you know the
art and science of making computers act
the way they do in the movies right
that's what it is but beyond that
and they keep coming up with new movies
yes and they just right exactly
we are driven by this kind of need to uh
sort of ineffable quality of who we are
which means
that the moment you understand something
is no longer ai right well like we
understand this that's just you take the
derivative and you divide by two and
then you
average it out over time in the window
so therefore that's no longer ai so the
problem is unsolvable
because it keeps kind of going away this
creates a kind of illusion which i don't
think is an entire illusion
of either there's very simple task based
things you can do very well in over
engineer
there's all of ai and there's like
nothing in the middle like it's very
hard to get from here to here
and it's very hard to see how to get
from here to here and i don't think that
we've done
a very good job of it because we get
stuck trying to solve the small problem
that's in front of myself included i'm
not going to pretend
that i'm better at this than anyone else
and of course all the incentives in
academia
and in industry are set to make that
very hard because you
you have to get the next paper out you
have to get the next product out you
have to solve this problem
and it's very sort of naturally
incremental and none of the
the incentives are set up to allow you
to take a huge risk
unless you're already so well
established you can take that big risk
and if you're that well established that
you can take that big risk then you've
probably spent much of your career
taking these little risks relatively
speaking
and so you have got a lifetime of
experience telling you not to take that
particular big risk right so the whole
system is set up to make progress very
slow that's fine
it's just the way it is but it does make
this gap seem really big which is my
long way of saying
i don't have a great answer to it except
that
stop doing n equals 1 at least try to
get n equal 2
and maybe n equals 7 so that you can say
i'm gonna or maybe t
is a better variable here i'm going to
not just solve this problem i'm going to
solve this problem and another problem
i'm not going to learn
just on you i'm going to keep living out
there in the world and just seeing what
happens and that we'll learn something
as designers
and our machine learning algorithms and
our ai algorithms
can learn as well but unless you're
willing to build a system
which you're going to have live for
months at a time in an environment that
is messy and chaotic you cannot control
then you're never going to make progress
in that direction so
i guess my answer to you is yes my idea
is that you should it's not no
it's yes you should be deploying these
things and
making them live for months at a time
and be okay with the fact that it's
going to take you five years to do this
not rerunning the same experiment over
and over again and refining the machine
so it's slightly better at whatever
but actually having it out there and
living in the chaos of the world
and seeing what its learning algorithm
say can learn what data structure can
build and how it can go from there
without that you're going to be stuck
ultimately what do you think about
the possibility of n equals one growing
is a probably crude approximation but
growing like if you look at
language models like gpt3 if you just
make it big enough
it'll swallow the world meaning like
it'll solve all your t
to infinity by just growing in size
of this taking a small over-engineered
solution
and just pumping it full of steroids in
terms of compute
in terms of size of training data and
the young lacuna style cell supervised
or
open ai self-supervised just throw all
of youtube
at it and it will learn how to reason
how to paint how to create music how to
love
all that by watching youtube videos i
mean i can't think of a more terrifying
world to live in than a world
based on youtube videos but yeah i think
i think the answer that i just kind of
don't think that'll quite well it won't
work that easily
right you will get somewhere and you
will learn something which means it's
probably
worth it but you won't get there you
won't solve the
you know here's the thing
we build these things and we say we want
them to learn but what actually happens
and let's say they do learn
i mean certainly every paper i've gotten
published the things learned i don't
know about anyone else
um but they actually change us right we
react to it differently right so we keep
redefining
what it means to be successful both in
the negative and the case but also in
the positive in that oh well this is
this is a
this is an accomplishment i'll give you
an example which is like the one user
subscriber g2 let's let's get completely
out of machine learn well not completely
but mostly out of machine learning
think about google people were trying to
solve
information retrieval the ad hoc
information retrieval problem forever
i mean first major book i ever read
about it was what um 71
i think was when it came out anyway it's
you know we'll treat everything as a
vector and we'll do
these vector space models and whatever
and that was all great and we made very
little progress
and we made some progress and then
google comes and makes the ad hoc
problem seem pretty easy i mean it's not
there's lots of computers and databases
involved but
you know and there's some brilliant
algorithmic stuff behind it too
and some systems building um but the
problem changed
right if you've got
a world that's that connected so that
you have you know there are 10 million
answers
quite literally to the question that
you're asking
then the problem wasn't give me the
things that are relevant the problem is
don't give me anything that's irrelevant
at least in the first page
because nothing else matters so
google is not solving the information
retrieval problem at least not
on this web page google is minimizing
false positives
which is not the same thing as getting
an answer it turns out it's good enough
for what it is we want to use google for
but it also changes what the problem was
we thought we were trying to solve in
the first place
you thought you were trying to find an
answer but you're not where you're
trying to find the answer but it turns
out you're just trying to find an answer
now yes it is true is also very good at
finding you exactly that web page of
course you trained yourself to figure
out what the keywords were to get you
that web page
but in the end by having that much data
you've just changed the problem into
something else you haven't actually
learned what you set out to learn
now the counter to that would be maybe
we're not doing that either we just
think we are
because you know we're in our own heads
maybe we're we're we're learning the
wrong problem in the first place but i
don't think that matters i think
the point is is that google has not
solved information retrieval google has
done amazing service i have nothing bad
to say about what they've done lord
knows my entire life is better because
google exists um informed for google
maps i don't think i've ever found this
one
where is this like 95 i see 110 and i
see but where did where
1495 go um you know so i'm very i'm very
grateful for google
but you know they just have to make
certain the first five things are right
and everything after that is wrong
you